[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast cat
extravaganza live stream number 38
with dr heather heing and myself brett
weinstein
we are continuing to hurtle through 2020
as we expect
are you so we certainly hope so yes
exactly it's really better than the
alternatives as they say stagnating in
2020
not anyone's choice where you want to
stay you want to get through this as
quickly as possible just head down
go for it yeah all right so i understand
we have a
correction off the top yes we do have a
correction off the top but um let me
actually
before even going right there at the top
say
uh because we have many new viewers um
there have been questions about how it
is that people get questions to
us uh so uh if you're watching this live
on youtube
uh you can uh do a super chat question
which involves paying
to youtube and we will take as many of
those super chat questions
based on how much you you uh gave
in the first hour and in the second hour
we will
um take as many of your questions as we
can based on the order in which you
you put them in so and then each hour
each each episode we will take some of
the few that we missed the previous time
that we thought were particularly
worthwhile
so it's about super chat and if you have
no idea what i'm talking about but
you're live
in youtube right now we have i believe a
moderator
there who will be able to answer
questions if you don't know what that
means
so so i should also just say we don't
love
asking for money but uh since we were
so um colorfully ejected from the
academy
uh this is a large fraction of how we
keep our family float so we very much
appreciate
the support that you give us through
this mechanism and
so far it has been working pretty well
we are um
hopefully going to deliver a mechanism
that will improve the functionality uh
even more in the near term so keep your
eye out for that
yeah exactly okay so correction right
off the bat last time in episode 37
we talked about a paper
uh published in nature finding that uh
uvc light in the 207 to 222 nanometer
range
uh has proven to be effective against
uh several coronaviruses they did not
actually check stars cove too but to
they have also found it effective
against uh influenza
and so uh extrapolating they thought
okay maybe this is
maybe this is actually going to be
effective um and
we then had a discussion i i love
discussion this is not on you at all
um in which while i didn't explicitly
say i basically
implied very strongly that um that
there this is one more piece of evidence
that being outside
is going to be effective against um
coronavirus and there is there is
lots of evidence that being outside is
actually protective
um but uvc light and this was actually
um
i first was alerted to this in a
superchat question from last time
the uvc light actually doesn't get to
the earth's surface
that uvc is in the 100 to 280 nanometer
range
and between 100 and 200 nanometers or so
it's totally blocked by
o2 by just diatomic oxygen and between
200
and 280 nanometers it's blocked by
triatomic
oxygen which is also known as ozone
so the ozone layer also blocks a lot of
the uvb light which is up to 315
nanometers and uva
is almost entirely unblocked by the
atmosphere
and so it's the ground that's in the 315
to 400 nanometer range so
all of that is a little bit a little bit
technical and maybe more than anyone
wants to know but the point
is that uh the germicidal uv
light in hvac systems and closets and
you know
in a number of places um could be
very effective uh but this is not a
place it seems that spending time
outdoors is actually going to be
directly helpful in combating
um either trans getting being having co
stars go to transmitted to you or uh
having a lower uh uh lower virulence of
the disease coping 19 should you get it
so i just want to unpack this a little
bit because the message here
is complex it's an error correction that
as far as i can tell has
zero implication for what you should do
the outside is still
very safe especially during the day when
uv light
does some purifying though that's
apparently not the only reason that
outdoors is safe even at night you have
the large volume of air which reduces
the uh viral load below the threshold
that you're likely to get it so
outdoors is great and as we keep saying
the clock is ticking
if you're in the northern hemisphere the
sun is shining spend some time outside
now because winter is coming and you are
going to be driven
indoors much more than you'd like so
just even at the level
of your mental well-being drink in as
much of that
beautiful outdoor stuff as possible so
that when you're stuck inside in
february
you don't feel like you've been trapped
for a year yeah
speaking of a bit uh we had talked early
uh you you had suggested that you were
concerned um
in you know april may about what was
going to happen to the homeless
communities
um because um they were so packed
together and they basically have nowhere
to go
um and you know interestingly we're not
seeing
um vast outbreaks among the homeless
well what don't the homeless have access
to
it's indoor spaces for the most part and
even when they do they often
aren't choosing to to go there right so
populations even um within sort of tent
cities
are being exposed to high air flow
almost all the time
and so have relatively low density of
the viral particles
which are which are necessary for both
being getting the disease and
having worse outcomes higher density
means higher likelihood of contracting
and worse outcomes
now if i might i would like to tack a
couple things onto this
um important correction with no
implications for your behavior oh so the
point of that
study then was that we could introduce
this uvc into our indoor environments
where it would be useful but it would
have to be
done technologically and it see it seems
to have as far as we know
it has now adverse health effects uvc
right so all of the you know beware of
uv
that we hear about with regard to skin
cancers
itself requires an asterisk for sure
because there is good evidence and i
haven't pulled it up so i can't i can't
pinpoint exactly the papers but
um actually the protective effects of
the uva uvb
light seems to outweigh the risks of
skin cancers so that that is an aside
but uvc even among the people even among
the you know the many dermatologists who
will say
absolutely never should you be exposed
to uv light you need to slide yourself
with sunscreen and wear hats at all
times and all this
um no one is saying at the moment that
there are adverse health effects to
exposure to uvc but of course
given that we haven't been exposed
because we've always lived on this
planet
who knows who knows what we aren't
noticing right now there are a couple
things i've got attack on here because
during my uh telomere phase as you'll
recall
um there was a uh a discovery that gave
me
particular joy associated with the fact
that dermatologists
were talking themselves silly about the
following
observation the expectation was
that exposure to uv causes cancer every
everybody who was dermatologically aware
knew that but it was becoming clear that
people that have very sun damaged skin
farm workers cowboys people who work
under the hot sun
enough that their skin is visibly sun
damaged have very low rates of cancer
right and so uh it happens that my
telomere work
gives us exactly the reason for this and
it tells you where to draw the line
so first of all sun damaged skin is
damaged
right um it loses its elasticity it
doesn't do
the jobs that skin does that's a healthy
young skin does
as well as it doesn't do it as well as
healthy young skin
but if you are exposed to the sun
continuously and it is damaging tissue
such that you are basically
turning over your cells at a high rate
but you are not
getting so much intensity that it is
causing genetic damage which causes
which is mutations which cause tumors
and what you are doing is effectively
aging your skin
artificially quickly but if you're aging
it without
mutating it then the point is that is
expending
your lifetime capacity for repair and
your lifetime capacity for repair
is what gives you the danger of tumors
because
the capacity of one cell to reproduce
itself many times
after it's had a mutation gives you a
big patch of cells that can get a second
mutation that will turn it into a tumor
but people whose skin is artificially
old because they've spent a lot of time
in the hot sun without getting
sunburns they are they when they get a
mutation
it creates a much smaller patch of cells
and so they are actually
protected by the damage so so once your
skin
is no longer capable of repair you won't
ever have youthful looking skin again
but you are also very unlikely to get
cancer in that skin
if you didn't get uh sunburns along the
way
that's that's that's the key thing and
so this also explains the other
interesting phenomenon which was
long known which was that sun burns are
the thing that leads to cancer but it's
early sunburns that lead to cancer later
in your life
so the early sun burns you get a
mutation in a cell from uv light
that cell then starts reproducing uh in
an
unregulated way it becomes a patch of
cells which is a mole basically
and then it stops at its telomeric limit
well the bigger the patch of cells is
when it reaches that limit the greater
the chance that one of those cells will
get a second mutation
that frees it from the limit and turns
it into a tumor so
anyway the the bottom line here at some
level is
uh biology is always a complex system
and the answers aren't necessarily what
you expect and you know turns out
sunscreen which we were told that we you
know shouldn't dare go outside without
it uh during the summer it has many
negative effects
that going out in the sun has many
positive effects that those effects are
not necessarily ones you'd predict like
the vitamin d protective effect against
kovid
so let's um let's actually just talk a
little bit more about
um what what we have done and what we
did with our with our kids
early on when all of the advice and
every time we'd send them to school or
camp or something we were told you know
you have to pack a tube of sunscreen and
probably come back empty and all of this
and we
we didn't do this um so i'd like to
share just a little bit about you know
how and how and why um but also say that
um your point that
early sunburn predicts later cancer
uh does raise the issue of okay what is
the boundary between a burn and a tan
and yo tan is this protective response
by the skin
but of course almost everyone has had
the
experience of you know spending a little
bit too much time outside thinking you
got away with it thinking it went to tan
and then finding that it was actually a
burn underneath and so
this like basically boundaries between
categories and every complex system that
you can name
is fuzzy right and so you know you want
to avoid getting too near that
that border between tan and burn as well
well i agree
the problem is it's fuzzy in the moment
in other words
you will have a burn before you have any
evidence that you have a burn
on the other hand experience is analog
but the actual like did it mutate or did
it not is digital
well it's not even did it mutate because
you may not end up with a mutation
did you damage tissue such that it
requires replacement so that you end up
with the sloughing of skin that comes
with the burn
the alternative being your skin
anticipates damage based on detecting a
lot of sunlight and it
darkens if you're light skinned it
darkens the color of your skin
in order to protect the cells that are
there and so the tan
the sweet spot is where you got enough
sun to trigger this but you didn't get
so much sun that you damaged tissue and
then
genetic damage is one layer beyond that
and that's the thing that you have to
worry about now here's an interesting
phenomenon
so i used to burn very very easily and i
did get some of those sunburns uh
in youth that tend to predispose a
person to skin cancer
but i've also learned just by observing
my own interaction
with the world how to manage it without
sunscreen right
so that hat on my twitter profile is
part of my strategy when i'm in the
field especially in the tropics is that
that's great it's also great for rain
um it keeps the rain off of
off of your face which is really very
useful but that's a great conversation
starter
uh it's a terrible conversation starter
people assume it's some sort of a
prop right um but anyway the the thing
that i learned about myself
which i've now taught my kids and when
they think of it it works for them too
is that you can get a lot of sun
exposure where you're headed towards a
burn
and then you can take a short break like
a five minute break in the shade or if
there's no shade you can turn so a
different side of you is facing the sun
and it seems to reset some sort of
counter and
the thing that i think is interesting is
it suggests an
a process that is analogous to what we
now know about covet infection
so covet infection at least as our
current model looks
there's like a bucket and that bucket as
long as it doesn't reach the top
means that even if you encountered some
covid you're very unlikely to get sick
it's only when the bucket overflows
because you've had
exposure over some period of time and
the bucket filled up
that you're likely to get it which means
if you're outside which is
constantly emptying the bucket you're
very low risk
so viral particles fly away from you
right and so there's something
and uh i'd be hard-pressed to tell you
what it is i don't know but there's
something about
the mechanism with respect to the sun
damage
there's something about the skin that is
able to tolerate a certain amount of
sun intensity and if you just keep
building it up
you it's like it's like a bucket that
has a hose in it
that's bigger you know that's putting in
more water than the leak in the other
side of the bucket the bucket eventually
overflows
but if you allow it to drain and
draining in the case of the sun exposure
it's just a matter of giving it some
time in which you're not bombarding it
with new
sunlight it seems to reset something and
so the thing that's surprising to me
is that it's not it's not like you catch
an hour in the sun
you need a half an hour in the shade
it's half an hour in the sun you need
two or three minutes in the shade nor
can you just count up the number of
minutes
you want to spend in the sun and say
okay i'm just going to take that all at
once
you know say say you have skin that can
tolerate three hours
um that you have calculated can tolerate
three hours in the sun
at a time well that's that's youthful
and extraordinarily sun resilient skin
um but actually say you did it for three
hours you could probably take a break
and at three hours you need maybe 15 20
minutes
and go back out again yeah now this this
really does seem to be
the experience i have i have less direct
empirical experience just because i
don't i don't tend to burn but we've
seen it with you
and both of our children as well yeah
the other the last thing i would say and
first of all this is just my experience
you know it's not uh it's anecdote at
best
so your mileage is almost certainly
going to vary and you have to
figure out your own pattern um but i
sometimes find that when i blow it a
little bit and i go too far
and i know this because when i come in
finally you know my skin is hot
and that's like i did is that a burn you
can go a certain amount too far
and then it doesn't end up being a burn
so there's some sort of
uh you have exceeded tolerances but not
so much that it's gone critical
phase which allows you to actually know
where you are in
finding that border but it requires that
you pay attention to the feedback your
body is giving you
yeah it requires that you have a sense
of what your skin
and your breathing and everything else
about your physiology normally feels
like so that as
it begins to send you warning signals
excuse me
you are in a position to read them and
to receive them yeah
absolutely and a lot of things work this
way medically speaking we're paying
attention to the patterns even if you
don't know what the underlying mechanism
is you can uh manage things absolutely
all right shall we get on to um the
i'll let you introduce the uh the topic
yeah
i guess uh yeah let's talk about um
the seattle police chief resigning now
this is carmen best
uh who announced her resignation in a
letter um
to her staff i think it was yesterday so
um on august 10th
uh to be effective september 2nd uh this
happened after the
seattle city council voted to
significantly cut her pay
as reported in the seattle pi um the
post-intelligencer also yesterday she
had been critical
of the chop jazz chop um especially in
the wake of
killings of two african-american men and
so zach if you would show
yet another murder in this area
identified as the top
two african-american men dead at a place
where they claim to be
working for black lives matter but
they're gone they're dead now
and we've had multiple other incidents
assaults
rape robbery and shootings
and so you know this is something that's
going to need to change
we're asking that people remove
themselves from this area for the safety
of the people
if they care about people they're going
to have to try to help us
to make it safe not opposed to anybody's
issue or concerned
they certainly can't demonstrate you
know and peacefully any place
but they can't possibly take over a
neighborhood and cause the crime levels
to go up like this
two men are dead two men are dead
and a child a 14 year old is
hospitalized and we don't know
what is going to happen to that kid
enough is enough here
so we can't hear that when you guys can
but um
uh she finishes with enough is enough
and this was back
on june 29th this is a press conference
that she held on june 29th
and and now she's done she's just she's
not
going to take it anymore well
she has faced some uh
she has had a significant pay cut yep
and she has also had her home protested
and so in some sense what is taking
place is you have
a police chief who's being hamstrung
in her job who is now being exposed
to very personal attacks i mean imagine
having people
protest you doing your job at your
home that's a very threatening
phenomenon not just socially
and then these uh insane demands to
defund the police
right um are actually which are what
resulted in
her um having to accept a pay cut if she
had a significant pay cut if she was to
keep her job
right and so this is now um
it's the mirror of the star of the beast
strategy
that the right has employed against
governance
where the idea is well maybe you don't
attack the structures themselves
but you eliminate their ability to
function you you strangle them
financially if the point is
let's render these institutions so bad
that everyone can agree that they are
not functional and therefore need to be
disappeared entirely
defunding them first is a brilliant
first step
so uh you know how how can you guarantee
that policing will get worse rather than
better
you give it fewer resources uh you give
less time
for you know mental health checks and
actual legitimate and real training
and uh you lower the pay so that people
who are considering going into the force
are less likely to choose that job
and you uh will therefore as fewer and
fewer people want to join the force have
to lower the standards of people you
accept into the force
this is guaranteed the defund the police
even if we only accept it as
a even if we accept the you know the
mild version of what defund the police
means which we've talked before about
whether or not that is actually what
what is being argued for but even if we
just accept that what people are arguing
for is that money has to be pulled out
of of policing you know is is there
excess in police departments as in every
other bureaucratic department in the
world
certainly right but the idea that we are
going to pull money
and therefore make it a less attractive
job for people
thus guaranteeing that the people who go
into it are going to be
less likely to be the highly empathic
and skilled people who we want
as our policemen is guaranteed to make
police brutality worse rather than
better
yeah and the simple fact that we are
being asked to consider
how we would like to see police
resourced in
isolation is is evidence that this is
not an honest conversation we are
involved in
it is quite possible that you could get
away with half as many police
but you would get away with half as many
police by virtue of the fact that you
had taken care of the things that the
police are now
forced to take care of by other
mechanisms and of course
we will be told that well that's what
we're saying just shift that money into
community programs
you cannot start there if you want to
render
the police uh less necessary by fixing
other parts of society you have to start
with that if you pull the police
first even if you shun stuff into other
programs that you think are going to
work first of all you don't know if it's
going to work
you don't know that the political
structure will end up maintaining that
money
there what you're simply going to do is
reduce the level of enforcement and
therefore you're going to increase the
brutality of it because
in part the brutality of policing is a
mechanism for doing it on the cheap
right and you know it's it's absolutely
true it's been noted by many people
um that police have begun to do you know
untrained for this work and never what
policing was supposed to be about
some of the basically first responders
on mental health issues
right and this is not uh where what we
what we should want our police to be
doing and i can basically guarantee you
that it's not what the police want to be
doing
yeah right no one wants to be called in
to respond
to the mental health situations when
they are not themselves and that is not
the career they have chosen nor are they
trained to do it
so do we need systems in place with
people who are trained to actually be
dealing with the mental health crises
that we are seeing revealed
on our streets and in you know the many
domestic abuse calls for instance
for sure but uh that that money
those those systems have to be
functional before you start to unravel
uh the policing system yeah so that's
not really what's being
debated no this is this is a uh a
movement that has discovered that it has
power
and your willingness to accept that the
police should
obviously be defunded is a litmus test
to see whether you are for us or against
us
well this reminds me rather a lot of
what happened at yes evergreen
right i mean we we we had this carmen
best
as far as i understand it has been the
police chief in seattle for for not too
many years but she's been on the force
for almost 30.
and i think she was seattle's first
african-american police chief
and of course in a in a movement just as
she says in that clip
in a movement that is declaring itself
to be a bla about black lives matter
uh why is it that black men are being
killed
and you know in a movement that
proclaims to be about black lives matter
why is it that seattle's first
african-american police chief
is feeling that it is that is necessary
for her to step down this is clearly not
um you know being being black isn't
sufficient to be
uh to be exalted in this movement you
have to be
of a particular political bent in order
to be exalted in this movement
and um police chief stacy brown at
evergreen
was i know more about stacey brown than
i do about carmen best but carmen best
appears to just be a good and honorable
cop and stacy brown
absolutely 100 was and still is she's
just no longer a police chief on a
college campus
she was herself an evergreen alum she
was explicitly about uh working on a
policy of
anti-police brutality and trying to fix
relationships between police
and their constituents and she took no
end of abuse from
from moment one from her swearing-in
ceremony uh
from the people at evergreen and sure
enough she was stood down and she ended
up having to resign because
because she had the authority to do her
job taken away from her
by in the case of evergreen the
president of evergreen
and she felt that if she remained in the
job
someone was going to get hurt or worse
and that that she would feel responsible
for it even though she had had
all of the ability to do her job taken
away from her
this i am sure is what police chiefs
all over the country are now feeling yes
and we also have the obvious test
of the insight of those who are
demanding these changes so those who
have now
driven chief best from office
have instituted their utopia at small
scale
it very quickly resulted in shootings
including a fatal shooting um it
resulted in
extortion from shop owners and basements
and rapes and assaults
right yep so the point is this is a test
of the claim that the community can
police itself better
no it can some of us knew that was
coming but okay now you've tested it in
a major american city and you've seen
what happens
you saw this at evergreen inside of
hours of
the president of the college standing
the police down
you had a violent mob students were uh
attacked um you had them stopping
traffic looking apparently
for me and then we've got a third case
we've got uh portland where
the mayor who is also the police
commissioner has
hobbled the local police resulting in
nightly violence at first against the
hatfield courthouse
and now it has moved into neighborhoods
there's
very shocking video of these rioters now
telling citizens that they will burn
their apartments
down apparently the crime is for looking
out the window at the
riot going by on the street so anyway
how many of these would you need before
you got the message that all these
people who claim to be authorities on
how much policing is necessary and how
easily
and how much better things will be if we
eliminate it how much evidence would you
need that they have no [ __ ] clue what
they're talking about when it comes to
the role that policing plays
in our country yeah they don't it's
obvious every time they try it
they can't keep it together for you know
a week
that's right um and just we might
introduce this this is from a week ago
now
zach if you would put this on screen new
york times op-ed from august 3rd 2020 by
chuck lovell
who is the chief of the police bureau in
portland um newly so
the former police chief stepped down and
i think appointed him
um he skipped a number of rungs in the
usual hierarchy to
obtain this position he is himself a
black man
and he says i mean this is a this is a
honestly a pretty weakly
worded op-ed but even so
it says things like people here's
um this here people protested peacefully
while others engaged in dangerous
activities that could have resulted in
injury and even death
so we have we have the police chief
of the city that we happen to live in
that has been
at the forefront of the media fight for
narrative
uh and neither of the polarized
sides of the mainstream media narrative
have gotten this right
and you know we've we've talked about
this before and and and so have others
no the city was not on fire nor was it
limited to two square blocks
no uh the protesters were not the only
people on the streets
reliably like clockwork uh
relatively shortly after the sun went
down um and sometimes later
uh the protesters became rioters
some of those are the same people many
of them are not it was like a change of
scene
um yes actually i want to
put something up here is that could you
put up the thing on propaganda
so what i'm going to show you here is a
blog post
that came up on the portland subreddit
today can you scroll up a little bit
so this is a remarkable piece
in which a strategy called
uh darvo is that right the second
paragraph there
institutional darvo yeah so what this
piece
which stands for deny attack and reverse
victim and offender
yes so your brain is about to hurt if
you try to puzzle through this this is
um somebody associated with this protest
riot movement who is arguing
that the government is now engaged in a
kind of propaganda
in which they are attacking innocent
people
that they are reversing victim and
victimizer
for the purpose of gaslighting the world
into thinking
that the protesters are violent
now the problem here is that this is the
exact inverse of the story
i can't say it's the exact inverse in
every instance
has any cop misbehaved during this
probably oh
and we know that we know that's true but
but the point is
they are describing the exact strategy
that they are involved in
they are pretending to be a non-violent
movement but there is a reliable shift
each and every night and really i think
it's each and every night for the last
70 there's been a reliable shift
in the direction of violence that
violence has been directed at federal
buildings now it's being directed
at the police union and neighborhoods
and the point is look there's not even a
set of demands here that we can evaluate
right the demand is effectively oh get
rid of the police
right how many what fraction of the
population actually thinks is a good
idea
tiny if even that but get rid of the
police is
the excuse for
a violent attack on the structures
of civilization that demands some kind
of response
now i'm not excited to see that response
in my city i don't like
seeing police dressed up in riot gear
you know roughing people up throwing
them into vans any of this stuff but
the alternative apparently is letting
them do what they want which doesn't
make any sense so
it doesn't and you know one of the
things i've seen in the local press
is this claim that oh well literally
portland is a protest city like anything
that happens and people just go on the
streets people
show up because portland is about
protest and frankly i've never heard
that before
we moved here this and you know now
looking back at some of the history like
yeah
actually this this seems to be kind of
the ethos that you you know if you if
you have any kind of grievance at all
you're gonna people are gonna protest
will that be exacerbated under
conditions of lockdown 100
of course they are this is where people
go instead of clubs and bars because
there are no clubs and bars
slightly at the moment but not still
really uh
but you know the idea of that's what we
do
we protest really puts the lie to the
legitimacy of
any given protest like how like people
could be
sort of categorically less likely to
protest or more likely to protest and
that's a legitimate
thing to recognize about a population i
suppose but
if if the local media
is saying without any irony whatsoever
well of course there's protests that's
what we do doesn't that then
mean that maybe taking people at their
word that
they are protesting because this new
thing happened
is less legitimate if protest happens
for anything and everything
then the any given reason that is
trotted out for why protests is
happening
seems less legitimate because actually
what you've already told us is you
protest because you protest
you don't protest because there's a
cause for it
this is the flip side of the thing that
i always say which is that
yes i'm a liberal but i'm a liberal that
wants to see
change that will make society so good
that i get to be a conservative
and the point is if your point is no i'm
always going to be demanding change then
we can't take your demand for change
seriously you're a liberal because you
want to be a liberal you're not not a
progressive because
change is inherently the right thing you
want
we we want to obtain
something that is stable and still
changing
and moving because the environment will
change but that is stable
such that we can afford to to love the
state that we're in
well let's let's just put it simply a
change for its own sake is stupid
sometimes you are going to do more harm
than good with change now
that's not where we are we've got a lot
of positive change that we can engage in
from here
but we should be frightened about the
downside of it this is the thing
liberals tend to miss
is that the unintended consequences of
well-intended policies are sometimes
sufficient to um to argue against
implementing those policies at all
but i would say the flip and we've we've
talked about this before but i would say
just the flip side of that
is that conservatives are more likely to
miss the unintended consequences of
their innovations in the marketplace
that then cause downstream effects right
they miss market failure and things like
that
right um but nonetheless anybody whose
ethos is oh i'm a change person yeah
you're a changed person we haven't even
told you where you are you're a changed
person
no matter what right yeah i'm you know
i'm a restless person i always want to
be somewhere
other than where i am okay well you're
on a ship would you like to stay on the
ship or you want to just step
off into the deep blue i mean i guess
right so
um anyway we i we are always wrestling
with how to phrase this or where to
stand so that you can actually see
what's going on and increasingly i think
we've got some of the right elements
um on the table you know we've talked
about an autoimmune
reaction this a lot of this protest is
attacking the very things that make
things functional we've talked about the
verificationism
that allows people to arrive at these
crazy
conclusions we've talked about um the
fact that the
the uh movement itself appears to be
involved in a kind of collective
psychosis
but you've also talked about this uh
the sneetch's analogy yeah that there's
something about what is being said
that appears to be devoid of content
it's just group identifier stuff and it
could be as arbitrary as a star on your
belly
right and that we are confused by the
fact that there is content like oh
we should definitely defund the police
like that sounds like an argument
we should definitely defund the police
sounds like an analytical conclusion
that arises from an analysis rather than
you know like you know it could just as
easily be oh i you know i hum at this
pitch
right you know yes you do well i do now
but
um but anyway so i've been wrestling
with how to put these things together
how to even think about them correctly
yeah and i came up with this model which
unfortunately i'm going to hold up on a
piece of paper which is kind of old
school but
um anyway let's see here's my piece of
paper here's the model
that we are we live here in this
gully and the point is the political
winds can
push this ball one direction or the
other and it tends to
revert back to the middle you know the
liberals can get a little overly
enthusiastic with some of their
solution making and you know things
don't quite work out and then the
conservatives
say told you so was never going to work
and they dragged things back a little
bit
too far and we lose some of the gains
that can go on
indefinitely because what this is this
this depression there is mathematically
speaking a stable
equilibrium now the points i have
labeled a
and b here those are unstable equilibria
and the point is if you push this ball
far enough it reaches one of these
unstable equilibria and the next thing
that happens is you end up down here
wherever that is and my claim is going
to be
this doesn't have to be fascism and
communism
but it might as well be the point is a
historical process that pushes that ball
up to either a or b results in a
catastrophic uh destabilization a
disintegration
of something that was keeping you safe
and so my point is
you don't always like it where you're in
this gully here but it's
tolerable and what happens once you go
over one of these unstable equilibrium
points
is you end up somewhere completely
intolerable and the real question for us
is a what does that
and i'm going to argue that the snitch's
business has a lot to do with it that
the thing that tends to push you
over the edge is something that
historically causes you
instead of thinking about things
analytically to default to team
okay but okay so sneetches you know mask
wearing sneak juice and sneetches
without maga hat wearing sneetches and
sneetches with that's all the same thing
right
but the tribes that are defined by the
maga hat and the masks
and the stars on the bellies and all of
the rest
are then slotted by their enemies into
particular buckets and so um you know we
have pointed out
often that at least used to be i'm not
sure if it still is but on the official
black lives matter
page we see and you know in interviews
with the founders uh we see them saying
actually this is marxist we're trained
in marxist
stuff and that's what we're trying to do
and so you know to your point oh is it
you know is it communism is it fascism
is it marxism is it fascism it doesn't
need to be but those do seem to be the
two poles that we are
um oscillating between at least in terms
of mainstream media right now
and part of the problem i think
this is maybe not exactly to your point
but i do think that part of the problem
is there are many of us
actually on the left including many
people on the right who are saying
oh my god that's that's that's marxism
that they're
proclaiming because they're actually
saying it and you should believe them
when they say that that's actually what
they're doing because it looks like it
and also
they don't deny it so what the hell and
by the way look at these 18 examples
from history where marxism doesn't work
so let's not go there
on the other side you've got people
saying
trump's ascendancy to office is clearly
uh
an indicator that we're about to descend
into fascism and
there are um you know some people on the
right who
who see that there are pretty much
everyone in the far left you know the
people who are actually rioting and some
number of the people who are protesting
on the streets see it that way
but there are also many of us on the
left who say
don't like the guy disagree with these
policies don't think he's fit for office
but it doesn't look fascist right so um
we on the left can simultaneously say
don't want that particular executive
branch
to maintain but in terms of are we
struggling between communism and fascism
it actually doesn't look like this thing
over in the republican party right now
is is fascist well no it
so i agree with that to an extent okay
my real point is that there is tribalism
that exists
in this well right in the well
there's normal tribalism you've got
elephants and donkeys under the best of
circumstances
and it's not inherently bad right what
you have is a tension between
arguments right those who want
less meddling and more freedom and
therefore are willing to tolerate more
failure
more people falling off the bottom of
the ladder or something our intention
with those
who um want to make sure
that bad things don't befall you and so
they will actually remove too much of
the incentive for you to do good things
right so those two things are actual
arguments
right and where we are is something that
reasonable people can disagree over and
where we should want to be is some place
reasonable people can disagree over
my point is that those unstable
equilibria the two high points from
which you descend into madness
are places where there is no argument
what we effectively start doing is
teaming up
for violence and
this is the thing that i'm concerned
about is that history has some
mechanism as far as i know it doesn't
have a name right we might have a
description of it when things descend
into
marxism we might have a description of
it when things descend into fascism
as far as i know we don't have a
description for the general pattern
of a functional society that is ebbing
and flowing
has hit a tipping point and that tipping
point goes to this other type of
behavior and that other type of behavior
ends in
warfare genocide all of these things and
so that's what i'm hunting for is i
think we are
we are now watching and all of the
people that we are in contact with
are now grappling with how to describe
what they are seeing we are debating
over stuff
that literally i mean you know we've
been at are we really arguing about
whether males and females
are different at a biological level like
how could a conversation ever get that
dumb
it's inconceivable we're now doing this
with two plus two equals five
right is it possible the conversation
will ever get that dumb yeah
it actually apparently is that dumb i
will say that my own failure of
imagination
cannot figure out what gets dumber than
that one
it's hard to get done i'm waiting but my
point is
you have hit bottom we have hit bottom
on something
and that is the degree to which what we
are arguing over has
anything to do with an analysis of any
kind
at the point you are arguing about two
plus two equals five you are declaring
that you no longer care
about what is actual right um
it's pure solipsism and so my point is
pure solipsism
is the adult version of stars on your
bellies
so to those who would say but the other
side is fascism
anything is better than that it doesn't
matter as much
maybe that we say you know what i don't
even think that's fascism
it what matters more is actual
intellectual solipsism
is the end full stop like that that is
where you lose
all access to the gains from the last
300 years right
so this is this is the point about
autoimmunity
is that the people who are arguing
against logic itself
right and those who have signed up with
them and are making excuses for them
are arguing against what we have in
favor of something
they claim we could have now my point
would be
every single test of their intuition
about what we could have
descends into madness almost instantly
so we are listening to insane people who
have a claim about a world better than
this one
and we are no longer listening to people
who say this world has a hell of a lot
going for it
and the only right thing to do is to fix
the parts that didn't get there
to complete the project rather than
destroy the project we are in that
argument
and we are losing ground to the people
who want to destroy this world in the
hope or in the expectation that
something marvelous
as they see it will arise in its place
the only uh
we are losing ground because their
argument is no longer
an argument it is a threat
expand on that a little bit we are
losing ground ah we are losing ground
because
it's it it all sounded to er to all of
us like we were in conversation
and then it turns out no actually what
was maybe thinly veiled
is now just full-on threat yes and that
the way that this looks
i mean i'm beginning to get frustrated
with um
with our circle because our circle is
seeing so much
of this nonsense that it is just it
thinks its job is to catalog it have you
seen this crazy example have you seen
that crazy example look at what this
person claimed
oh my god it's gotten even worse right
and my point is
that that will work for some people
people who haven't yet seen it being
being presented with a list a catalog um
i feel a little like invoking yoda and
i'm not a huge star wars fan but i am
kind of a huge yoda fan
um there is no try there's
do and don't do right my point is
our circle being fascinated by all of
the various examples
is missing the boat because we're about
to lose the thing that is
feeding us that will provide our
descendants with the place to exist and
experience freedom and all of these
things and
the reason we are losing it is because
you know those who are good
at analysis default to it when something
comes in a
form we are purely being gaslit
right the argument two plus two equals
five is
purely gaslighting now i'm not saying
that everybody who's saying it knows
that
but i am saying that its function is to
take all of the people
who feel like no wait a minute let me
explain to you why 2 plus 2 does not
equal
5 and get them explaining it because
they're busy over here not paying
attention
right we are not paying attention to the
real thing which is
holy [ __ ] i think we just crossed that
threshold
that takes a functional entity and turns
it into madness
and the other thing if i can just put
the last piece in the puzzle as i see it
at the moment
i think we need to stop saying that
marxism doesn't work i think there's a
whole lot we can talk about here
because not work isn't really the
problem
it's that when it works it is completely
unacceptable from the point of view
of what actually makes sense to value as
a human being
in other words being existing
as a homo sapiens is not the valuable
thing
right the valuable thing has to do with
your ability to take the specialness
that comes along with being a homo
sapiens
and apply it to things that seem
worthwhile
so you know does north korea work
it it does i don't want to live like
that
in fact i would gladly i mean i think
you're going to have to define work then
well it persists
oh well mass famine and and mass deaths
and such
yeah but but the point is the entity
persists and we could say the same thing
about china in fact entity the political
entity
persists and the population even though
many individuals are lost along the way
in perfectly grotesque circumstances it
you know
it it does look like it's sticking
around and
china is not just sticking around china
is actually thriving economically and
with respect to its
global power and so the point is well
china's also moved into more of a
capitalist model sure but my point is
if you're going to make the argument
that won't work then china actually
tells you well that's not quite right
because whatever it thought it was doing
moved into something that made it
quickly powerful and ascendant
i still don't want to live under that
system and so
at some level a communism often does
fail
b when it succeeds it never does so
without
totalitarianism in tow for reasons that
i think we've described here
that because it is group selection
thinking
to imagine that people will behave
altruistically the way that a communist
system that functions works
is by realigning people's incentives by
threatening them
so you know the gulags come along with
functional communism and the point is
this so but just to put this in the
language that we've often used
elsewhere communism assumes that
external motivation
is the thing that is needed to get
people to do
the right thing and then and the right
thing
is then uh is
decided by defined by the state and
and the external motivator is almost
entirely stick no carrot
and we are not arguing that we should
have a carrot-based totalitarian
argument but rather
figure out a way to allow people to to
know themselves well enough
to motivate themselves internally to
produce and create and discover
and heal and do all of the other things
that humans do when we are at our best
rather than creating a system that
requires external motivators especially
in the form of the state
or corporations to impart on people what
it is that they should be doing
right or if i could put it a different
way and you know on the one hand
folks on the right thinking folks on the
right love to hear an analysis about why
communism does tend to come with
authoritarianism right
they're looking for that argument and
it's important to them but they over
apply it
so what i would argue is that our system
functions best
as a hybrid and it's not really
surprising that it functions best as a
hybrid this is a natural outgrowth
of thinking about complex systems and
diminishing returns
right any pure system has massive
failures associated with it because if
you maximize one thing you crash all the
other values
that means that a good system will
involve
getting 85 of some value but not seeking
100
and then you can have 85 percent of a
lot of things right so that principle
is important which is why i think people
actually get the question of socialism
wrong because their senses
well socialism is communism okay and
maybe there's an argument that's really
their flavors are the same thing um and
that therefore
anybody who has those inclinations is
necessarily
inviting gulags which is not the case
because it can certainly be true if you
take
my little trough model here we can say
that actually there are times
when you don't have enough socialism to
make your system work you're coming too
close to one of these maximization
places so you need more socialism does
that mean you're a socialist
no you need to pool enough of the risks
to guarantee that the people really at
the bottom of the socioeconomic ladder
don't fall off entirely
right right so what yeah what we really
need is a system
that leverages the great part of
capitalism
which is markets being applied to
problems that markets are good at
solving
while hedging out the bad parts that
allow people to discover
their internal motivations and act on it
and benefit from doing so
when it is in the service of the of the
society hell yeah
we want you to get paid handsomely
when you deliver something that improves
our lives a lot
right we want that to be the incentive
and that's the mythology of capitalism
and again
there are so many roots there it could
be discovery which is typically
uh what what stem people are doing you
know scientists and such and it could be
creation which may be more often in the
realm of art and literature
and and entertainment it could be
healing it could be
so many things it could be um production
it could be
you know organizing of those parts in
order to create an emergent hole that is
greater than this than the individual
parts there are many many ways to
actually add value right but you
you need to discover on your own what
your own
individual talents and proclivities and
passions are
and learn how to and you know for this
we need a system that doesn't destroy
children in school and doesn't drug them
it doesn't feed them screens it doesn't
tell parents they need to keep all risk
from children all of these things
such that by the time people in the
bodies of children become people in the
bodies of adults they're actually adults
as opposed to still acting like
unregulated
unable to be regulated six-year-olds
totally so i think that this is really
it's like
it's tragic that we're figuring out how
to phrase this at the point we are
arriving at the
possible uninvention of everything but
the idea
that the purpose of the protective
programs is actually to protect your
ability to innovate so that you can
deliver value which gets paid
back in a market is really i think the
right answer
and you can see how this works i mean
it's
obvious the fact is you want to be
protected from
failures that are not signal
right if you're innovating in the market
you want your failures that you could
have foreseen
to haunt you a bit so that you get
better at figuring out where the real
value is
but you don't want arbitrary stuff to
take you down so you don't want
you know except people do want their
good luck to raise them up
i mean this this is this is the problem
right that noise luck is noise
and people attribute their success that
was in fact a good lock to their own
skill
and they tend to attribute uh their
failures that was in fact bad luck to
bad luck
and if we are going to try to even out
the effects of noise it's going to
flatten out both the good and the bad
luck right we do not want to flatten out
the effects of
excellent choices and excellent skills
and poor choices and poor skills
but you know you can think of it like um
a tennis court right a really good
tennis court is one in which the luck
has been
as eliminated as much as possible that
is to say the surface is
perfectly even so nobody is benefiting
from a clump of
grass that causes a ball to take a bad
hop
you know the fact is some of the bad
hops would go against your opponent hey
yay some of the bad hops would go
against you god damn it that thing was
in the way i would have gotten the ball
if it hadn't been there
well there's something sorry but there's
something interesting to be thought
about here with regard to
you know players who you know every
every player in tennis has a preference
right hardcore
grass or clay and they've got to be
varied like grass has got to be the
noisiest of those surfaces i would think
although it's possible that clay
also the longer you play on clay the
longer you play on grass the more it
changes whereas hard surface is going to
remain entirely the same
throughout the game throughout a
competition anyway but
something i keep saying that people are
scratching their heads over is that
bad luck you're never going to hedge it
out but it's got to be randomly
distributed because if it isn't randomly
distributed it's not luck it's something
else
right so you know it's one thing if
they're imperfections on both sides of
the court and you both accept that the
game is gonna
you know the game is gonna be less good
at figuring out who the better player is
because
it may go one way or the other because
of something that was luck but
it shouldn't go in favor of one player
the luck shouldn't be you know
venus williams and not serena it should
have to time be one and half the time be
the other
and just i mean to continue with tennis
this is part of why you switch sides
it's not just about sun angle and such
but exactly
so the point is a really good game is
one that rand that
eliminates as much noise as possible and
randomizes its distribution so that what
you actually get is athletic prowess and
the thing is our market should be like
this too
you don't want the fact that you were
innovating
the next big thing you know you were
innovating uh
some sort of i don't know safety
mechanism or
fusion reactor that would free us from
energetic constraints and
then you got cancer and you couldn't
afford you know to fight it so
it wiped out your research program right
right so
you want a system that basically leaves
the
positive incentives in the market right
and eliminates
the luck aspect and what's more if we
can go back to your example about kids
and what they face
you do not want people innovating
badness
i've never ever heard a
proper argument that defends advertising
to children
to me advertising to children is an evil
i have asked people to give me any
valid argument in favor of allowing it
to exist i've yet to hear one that i
found even a little bit compelling
and the basic point is look in childhood
you should be protected from
economic forces that are trying to
persuade you of stuff for their good
that probably isn't in your interest and
this is a corruption so you know do you
want to be able to innovate anything
no i don't want you innovating sorry
mechanisms to get inside my kids head
and get them to
spend money they wouldn't spend or
demand things i don't
that i want there to be regulations that
prevent that right and so the point is
good regulation is regulation that
leaves the market to do things we want
done and doesn't allow it where
it accomplishes things that we shouldn't
want done like um
and those and what's in each of those
buckets is what we should be spending
our time
arguing about right yeah right rather
than whether
it is possible that two plus two equals
four is a white people thing
yeah so um i we are
we're closing out an hour here and i
think i will save
uh a short discussion of ibram x candy
for next time because
that seems um not in keeping but i did
want to do a brief reading
that i think is actually very much in
keeping with what we were just talking
about although it may not seem so
immediately this is a book called the
world beyond your head
on becoming an individual uh in an age
of distraction
it is an excellent book it is uh matthew
crawford's from 2015
and um his first book was called shop
class as soulcraft which i think i've
mentioned on our
on our live streams before i'm a huge
fan of this guy
he um i didn't look up his bio again
before coming on air so i may i may get
something wrong here
if i remember correctly he got his phd
in economics from the chicago school
from university of chicago
and took a job uh basically as a policy
wonk uh within the beltway in dc
and you know wrote these important white
papers and after a couple of years
realized that he was sort of
losing his will to live that he felt
like two people
maybe maybe at the most 20 are ever
going to read any of these things i
don't think i'm actually having an
impact on the world
you know clearly a brilliant guy totally
capable of being this kind of analysis
an analyst but he left
and he opened up a um i think mostly
vintage although i may have that wrong
motorcycle repair shop in virginia uh
and hence the
his first book shop craft as soulcraft
which is kind of a latter day zen in the
art of motorcycle maintenance both of
which i think are extraordinary books
this the world beyond your head on
becoming an individual in an age of
distraction
i just want to read a couple of a couple
of expert excerpts
from this today
first from a section he calls the
attentional commons
we have all had the experience of
sitting in an airport with an hour to
kill
and being unable to escape the
chattering of cnn
the audio may be turned off but if the
tv is within view i for one find it
impossible not to look at it
the introduction of novelty into one's
field of view commands what the
cognitive psychologists call an
orienting response an important
evolutionary adaptation in a world of
predators
an animal turns its face and eyes
towards the new thing
a new thing typically appears every
second on television
the images on the screen jump out of the
flow of experience and make a demand on
us
in their presence it is difficult to
rehearse a remembered conversation for
example
whatever trains of thought might
otherwise be pursued by those in the
room give way to a highly coordinated
experience not the near simultaneous
turning of a troop of macaques to face
the python that has appeared
but the involuntary glances of weary
travelers towards the
content on offer alternatively people in
such places stare at their phones or
open a novel sometimes precisely in
order to tune out the piped in chatter
a multiverse of private experiences is
accessible after all
in this battle of attentional
technologies what is lost is the kind of
public space that is required for a
certain kind of sociability
jonathan franzen wrote walking up third
avenue on a saturday night i felt bereft
all around me attractive young people
are hunched over their star tacks and
nokias with preoccupied expressions as
if probing a sore tooth
all i really want from a sidewalk is
that people see me and let themselves be
seen
a public space where people are not
self-enclosed in the heightened way what
happens
that happens when our minds are
elsewhere than our bodies may feel rich
with possibility for spontaneous
encounters
even if we do not converse with others
our mutual reticence is experienced
as reticence if our attention is not
otherwise bound up
but is rather free to a light upon one
another and linger or not
because we ourselves are free to pay out
our attention in deliberate measures
to be the object of someone's reticence
is quite different from not being seen
by them
we may have a vivid experience of having
encountered another person even if in
silence
such encounters are always ambiguous and
their need for interpretation gives rise
to a train of imaginings often erotic
this is what makes cities exciting
so uh remarkable
to my mind especially in the era of
covet when we have
so many fewer of these spaces right now
but
the fact is that even even before covet
even before the lockdowns
what he was writing about in 2015 is
even more true at the end of 2019
early 2020 before kovit that it is very
hard to find a public space anymore
even when you think you're in public
you're alone together as opposed to
maybe engaging even with strangers with
glances
with the understanding that we are
actually sharing our minds and
brains and bodies all in one space one
more
brief excerpt from the end of the book
what this boils down to please don't
install speakers in every single corner
of a shopping mall even its outdoor
spaces
please don't fill up every moment
between innings and a lazy college
baseball game with thundering excitement
please give me a way to turn off the
monitor in the backseat of a taxi
please let there be one corner of the
bar where the flickering delivery system
for bud light commercials is deemed
unnecessary because i am already at the
bar
the attentional comments is an idea that
i hope will catch on among those who are
in a position to make such sanctuaries
happen
building managers commercial real estate
developers and interior designers
here is a modest proposal could the
music be made opt-in rather than opt
out once every 20 minutes somebody in
the room would have to deliberately hit
a button to restart it and thereby
actively affirm yes
we want some emo in here we learned
encouraging things too
joy is the feeling of one's powers
increasing the experience of hitting
one's flow as a cook
or feeling one's awareness run out
through the contact patches of a
motorcycle's tires
seems to reveal something deep about the
situated embodied character of
impressive
human performance this is slightly weird
to be doing here because we are
explicitly
disembodied from those watching and from
those who will only be listening
but you know we're here embodied with
one another and
every day that we are smart enough to
make it happen during this season we are
going outside taking walks or bike rides
or getting our
kayaks into the water and just being
there in our bodies with our brands with
each other and our children
and it is fundamentally different and
being out there you know when you guys
were pulling the boats out of the water
a few nights ago
and i was just sitting watching first
the geese but then the other people on
the dock we were too far away to see
them directly it was too dark to make
eye contact
but they were there and we were there
and we were all there together in a way
that doesn't tend to happen anymore
yeah i agree and there was an awful lot
of
what i would say is superficial
camaraderie that
used to be exchanged just the simple
fact that you were
involved in the same activity as
somebody you know you would say
something about
how nice an evening it was for it or
whatever yeah and a lot of that has been
lost and
i must say when it does happen it feels
really really good it feels such a
relief feels human
right it feels like a reminder of what
we are that we are social beings that we
are not
just our brains we are not brains in
jars we are and we are not just our
bodies so when we go out and actually
engage in
sport or physical activity it's not and
now we put our analytical selves on hold
our creative selves
know like this is this is often the
place where the best ideas come from
right when you are not actively working
on
an intellectual puzzle or how to word
the thing it is it is
this place where you can you know be in
the moment fully
well and it is it's a very good
demonstration of exactly
um the thing that is lost
in this de-individuated communal view
which is not to say that there's not a
lot about what works that needs to be
communal but
the point is it's semi-communal the
thing that's great about communal is
the asymmetry of it that different
people with different perspectives find
themselves in the same space
and you know it just if you erase that
by either
forcing everybody to be alike or
policing what they say so that the
differences can't be seen
you just destroy such a large fraction
of what's important about
the humanness of it that's right and but
anyway i would also say just
on a bright note it is totally true that
many of these technologies just
obliterate some important social
interaction that once existed
but then others are arbitrarily created
so this
podcast is obviously you all
choosing to tune in a conversation
between us that isn't
exactly a conversation between us
because we're aware
that there's an audience and this is
specifically something we do
here so that you can tune it in but
we're also not
um you know it's a total fabrication no
it's obvious obviously
obviously we have conversations like
this elsewhere and have been for
decades else we wouldn't have been able
to show up on camera and start talking
right so the conversation is real
there's nothing inauthentic about it you
all know what you've signed up for we
know
why we're sitting here but the point is
it is a choice and it is a semi-social
choice because
although we're not interacting with
everybody who's paying attention we get
a lot of information back about what
people are thinking
and we get lots of interesting
communications that point our attention
to things
so anyway this is some new form right
it is and it it's uh you know
it's hopeful that even as certain things
are being destroyed other things are
wrestling their way into existence that
uh in some ways compensate for what's
been lost
yeah may they continue into the future
indeed
all right all right um i have a unity
announcement i probably should have done
it at the top
um unity 2020 is humming along
interesting things are afoot
we are gonna hold our next campfire
tomorrow that is to say
wednesday at four o'clock pacific
time we are going to have nate boyer
and john wood jr together in
conversation
should be great please tune in
i will announce it on my twitter feed
so will the articles of unity twitter
account
if you want details on where it's going
to be
our nomination process remains open we
are getting
tremendous number of nominations that
are excellent i
wasn't able to source an exact count for
how many novel nominations we've gotten
to date but we are rapidly approaching
the point
at which we will put at first some and
then all
of the qualified nominees on a page on
our site
where you will be able to debate the
merits of various candidates
so anyway it's exciting times and it's
very gratifying
to see the number of people who are
thoroughly dedicated to
saving the republic from the dire
circumstance that we seem to be headed
towards and are willing to invest their
time
and their their thought power in
figuring out how we might
thread this needle so thanks to all the
volunteers
and uh if you haven't joined us yet
please look into it at
articlesofunity.org and
uh at articles of unity on twitter
wonderful so consider joining us at
either
or both of our patreons where at either
of them
you can access private discord server
and at mine you can also act
become a dark horse member and get
access to a private
q a on the last sunday of every month we
have a clips channel dark horse clips
channel
which has i don't know four six
sometimes eight
clips from uh each of these shows uh
that go up
and they are shorter so more shareable
we probably will not be back on saturday
probably our next live stream will be
tuesday we of course have one in 15
minutes or so we'll be doing q a
um but there will be at least one dark
horse podcast dropping between now and
then
hopefully in a few days and maybe that's
it we'll be back in 15 minutes to answer
your super chat
questions all right everybody we'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you